tja eine riesenherausforderung und jetzt
ist er bei uns der arzt der als erster
dieses virus unter dem
elektronenmikroskop hatte jedenfalls in
deutschland dr wo man würfel ist das vom
institut für mikrobiologie der
bundeswehr
einen schönen guten abend nach münchen
schönen guten abend halo wird das auf
sie herr dr würfel eigentlich schräg
wenn man fragt ob sie sozusagen stolz
darauf sind als erster dieses virus in
deutschland nachgewiesen zu haben hat
man also etwas wie pioniergeist oder
können sie damit gar nichts anfangen
naja am institut für mikrobiologie der
bundeswehr beschäftigen wir uns immer
damit gefährliche krankheiten die
insbesondere auch unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten im einsatz bedrohen könnten
schnell zu erkennen und deswegen haben
uns natürlich auch mit dem damals neuen
corona virus was in china beschrieben
worden ist schon sehr früh befasst und
warnt deswegen auch darauf vorbereitet
das hat mich natürlich schon gefreut
dann zu sehen dass die arbeit die wir
hier im labor tagtäglich leisten damit
so einem fall auch funktioniert und wie
er dann die ersten waren die dieses
virus auch hier in deutschland bei dem
patienten den sie gerade gezeigt haben
nachweisen können jetzt wird sich der
laie vielleicht fragen wie kommt er
überhaupt die bundeswehr ins spiel
vielleicht können sie das grundsätzlich
noch einmal erklären wann haben sie mit
solchen viren zu tun
wir beschäftigen uns immer mit
gefährlichen krankheitserregern die eben
besonders für soldatinnen und soldaten
gefährlich werden können das sind zum
einen natürlich historisch die
krankheitserreger die als biologische
kampfstoffe eingesetzt werden können
aber zum glück gibt es ja durch die
waffen konvention hier eine deutlich
geringere bedrohung nur noch aber auch
andere krankheiten wie das ebola-virus
zb können gefährlich sein oder eben
viele andere virale krankheiten und
bakterielle und damit beschäftigen wir
uns hier als forschungseinrichtung der
bundeswehr
tagtäglich und deswegen sind wir auch
auf solche erreger wie das neue corona
virus dann sehr schnell vorbereitet
gewesen dass es unsere forschungsaufgabe
also sie waren vorbereitet sie hatten
informationen aus china wie detailliert
und umfangreich die waren das
kann ich schlecht beurteilen dazu können
sie vielleicht noch was sagen aber haben
sie denn damals als das dann in
deutschland auftauchte schon ansatzweise
mit der tragweite rechnen können die es
dann bekommen hat also zu unserer
vorbereitung muss ich sagen wir sind
halt sehr gut vernetzt wir arbeiten mit
vielen auch zivilen
forschungseinrichtungen in deutschland
und der ganzen welt zusammen und die
protokolle die professor posten in
berlin entwickelt hat haben wir auch
unmittelbar gleich sofort bekommen weil
wir immer in einem regen austausch
miteinander stehen deswegen wussten wir
bereits worauf wir uns da vorbereiten
müssen
die tragweite die das jetzt angenommen
hat die pandemische verbreitung die
haben wir damals natürlich auch nicht so
absehen können
insbesondere weil es ja auch gelungen
ist die allerersten patienten sehr
schnell zu finden und dann auch in der
sonder isolierstation in schwabing
erstmal zu behandeln ich würde gerne mit
ihnen noch einmal kurz zurück schauen
also das war was wir gerade schon
gesehen haben ganz am anfang zu beginn
dieser pandemie wir wollen den blick
aber vielleicht gerade auch noch mal
richten auf das was danach kam also da
waren auch viele stellen sicherlich
überfordert kann man mit sicherheit an
der einen oder anderen stelle dann auch
nicht verdenken es war das erste mal
dass deutschland mit so einer pandemie
zu tun hatte wir wollen noch mal gucken
auf das was ich danach abgespielt hat
und man muss ja dann auch die bilanz
ziehen nach diesem jahr dass die
pandemie noch längst nicht ausgestanden
ist jan frederik fischer noch mal dass
das hier unser leben einmal so sehr auf
den kopf stellen würde damit hätte vor
einem jahr wohl kaum einer gerechnet
gerade an den flughäfen den sogenannten
eintritts orten ist man sehr gut
gewappnet insofern ist die gefahr für
die deutsche bevölkerung ist sehr gering
doch schon ende februar wird der hotspot
heinsberg abgeregelt die politik sucht
jetzt händeringend nach antworten und
masken gleichzeitig führt die virus
angst zu leeren regalen und immer
schneller lernen wir händeschütteln ist
keine gute idee mehr
man geht lieber auf abstand doch noch am
vierten märz bilanziert das ernüchternd
die gefahr für die gesundheit der
bevölkerung wird in deutschland aktuell
als mäßig eingeschätzt mitte märz dann
die vollbremsung bars und restaurants
bleiben dicht genau wie museen kinos
oder spielplätze das sind maßnahmen
dieses in unserem lande so noch nicht
gegeben hat die natürlich einschneidend
sind aber sie sind im augenblick
notwendig auf die maßnahmen folgt eine
historische ansprache es ist ernst und
alle sollen mitmachen doch wie trägt man
eigentlich die maske und welche schützt
wirklich
deutschland diskutiert und trägt immer
mehr mund nasenschutz im sommer dann hot
spots in schlachthöfen aber auch
schlangen am check-in-schalter die
normalität scheint zurück und die
diskussion gehen weiter diesmal geht es
um beherbergungs verbote und
verpflichtende tests im herbst steigen
die zahlen wieder und antworten werden
gesucht jetzt soll ein neuer shutdown
das weihnachtsfest retten und todesfälle
verhindern
wenn er jetzt vor weihnachten sie viele
kontakte haben und anschließend es das
letzte weihnachten mit den großeltern
war dann werden wir etwas versäumt haben
das sollten wir nicht tun
nach dem fest starten dann endlich die
impfung doch es gibt zu wenig dosen und
mutationen bereiten sorgen die
konsequenz ein verschärfter shutdown und
hin und wieder nehmen wir natürlich auch
die user gerne hier mit in die sendung
lage schreibt über youtube es hätte nie
soweit kommen müssen wenn die politik
nicht versagt hätte dass seine
einschätzung
herr doktor würfel wir haben schon auch
vor der sendung gesprochen sie sind
natürlich auch mitglied und bzw
angehöriger sagt man der der bundeswehr
und dementsprechend es ist jetzt nicht
ihr auftrag die bundesregierung zu
kritisieren das respektieren wir
natürlich aber vielleicht ganz allgemein
aus medizinischer sicht wenn sie jetzt
auch einzelne äußerungen hören die wir
gerade im beitrag hatten da muss man
schon konzertieren am anfang war die
bedrohungslage vielleicht nicht für alle
so klar erkennen
oder er hat dieses neue pandemische
corona virus das stellt uns alle alle
menschen auf der welt vor sehr große
herausforderung
und man muss sagen dass keiner auf der
welt eine erfahrung mit solch einem
erreger hatte die letzte große pandemie
die wirklich vergleichbar ist das war
die grippe pandemie 1918
da war die zumindest europa gerade noch
durch den ersten weltkrieg gezeichnet
und damals gab es ganz andere
herausforderungen natürlich es gab aber
auch keine schnellen reisebewegungen
weltweit es gab aber auch noch keine
möglichkeiten einer erreger wirklich
frühzeitig zu finden und dann auch
sicher eine diagnose immer zu stellen
insofern ist es eine steile lernkurve
tatsächlich für alle und umso wichtiger
ist es dass wir jetzt alle zusammen
helfen und zusammen aufeinander achten
um diese ausbreitung möglichst gut in
den griff zu bekommen
wenn wir jetzt noch mal gucken auch auf
wie gesagt die vergangenen monate auch
gerade auf den sommer ich denke da jetzt
an die reisewelle zum beispiel in
deutschland oder auch an die diskussion
darüber wie nutze ich das tragen von
masken ist etwa sind dass diskussionen
die im nachhinein für sie auch manchmal
etwas absurd anmutet weil man eigentlich
schon hätte wissen können dass dass das
eine sinnvolle ist nämlich die masken
das andere aber mit sicherheit nicht
sinnvoll ist das fahren in den urlaub
und das massenhafte reisen ja das tragen
von masken ist in der tat eine der
wichtigen maßnahmen um die ausbreitung
des virus zu verhindern
insbesondere wenn man jetzt an die neuen
mutationen denkt da kann erst mal
notieren was will solange sich das virus
nicht weiter verbreiten kann und eine
mutation die es durch die masken trinken
lässt wird es auf absehbare zeit nicht
geben kann man damit die ausbreitung
minimieren
natürlich muss auch dabei an die
verantwortung jedes einzelnen jeder
einzelnen appelliert werden weil in der
tat reisebewegungen unnötige besucher
aber auch vielleicht die urlaubsreise
sind alles dinge die dazu führen dass
sich natürlich das virus weiter
verbreitet das virus kennt da weder
grenzen noch nimmt es irgendwie
rücksicht auf das erholungsbedürftigen
ist der menschen
ich verstehe das aber es ist so dass wir
hier eben noch weiter durchhalten
ja und natürlich auch warten auf den
impfstoff beziehungsweise der ist ja nun
da aber nicht in ausreichender menge wir
auch gerade nochmal aus brüssel gehört
haben das wird also auch noch ein
bisschen dauern trotzdem vielleicht noch
mal die frage auch an sie wie
wahrscheinlich ist es dass fragte
zumindest aus miesbach auf youtube dass
wir bis zum herbst einen grad der
immunität erreichen wohl durch impfungen
aber eben auch durch ansteckungen durch
den wir dann im herbst also keine
einschränkungen mehr brauchen wie ist da
ihre einschätzung
ja das ist eine frage die dürfen sie
eigentlich den biologen stellen sondern
müssen sie dem hersteller den
herstellern stellen die logistikern
es ist so wenn der impfstoff angewandt
wird wenn die jetzt zur verfügung
stehenden emea impfstoffe angewandt
werden können zb dann haben wir eine
sehr gute immun wirkung bei denen die
geimpft worden sind die große
herausforderung ist jetzt natürlich
diesen impfstoff in ausreichender menge
zu produzieren und dann in sona weise zu
verteilen dass möglichst schnell
möglichst viele menschen zu anfang
natürlich die die unter dem größten
risiko stehen impfung erhalten können an
diese frage schließt sich dann sind
jetzt also doch schon beim thema impfung
ist sie das jetzt mal nach vorne lässt
den blick über youtube würde es sinn
ergeben die impfstoffe nach wirksamkeit
den altersgruppen zuzuordnen
insofern ist die zuordnung fähige
unterschiede gibt kann man darüber
natürlich dann auch nachdenken und wir
haben in deutschland eine sehr gute
äußerst erfahrene ständige
impfkommission da sind exzellente
expertinnen und experten drin
und die werden das entsprechend bewerten
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt stand heute ist
die auswahl für uns natürlich mit 2 m
rna impfstoffen die über alle
altersgruppen eine sehr gute wirksamkeit
zeigen noch recht einfach da gehen eben
andere kriterien
am ende vor wie eben beispielsweise das
risiko werden dann weitere impfstoffe
hinzukommen was wir hoffentlich in den
nächsten wochen monaten haben werden
dann muss man das neu betrachten und
dann wird es sicherlich auch eine
aktualisierung der entsprechenden inseln
federung geben ganz allgemein gefragt
wie viel hoffnung setzen sie auf die
impfkampagne auch wenn die etwas
wackelig angelaufen ist
gerade in bezug natürlich auch darauf
dass es immer wieder mutationen gibt wie
große sorge bereitet ihnen das also
zunächst einmal ist die impfung ein
wichtiger weg aus der pandemie weil wir
müssen es schaffen dass eine große
anzahl von menschen das virus schon mal
gesehen hat und auf diese weise eben
eine immunität erworben hat das kann
passieren durch die krankheit selber ist
dann natürlich mit dem risiko schwerer
verläufe gerade bei risikopatientinnen
patienten behaftet oder das kann ihnen
durch die impfung passieren die sehr
viel besser verträglich natürlich ist
als die krankheit und vor allem auch
möglicherweise eine belastbarere
immunität erzeugt man darf nicht
vergessen das virus hat ein gewisses
interesse daran dass die immunität in
den menschen die es befällt nicht allzu
stark ausgeprägt ist und dass da tut's
auch etwas dafür um die möglichst
begrenzen
während dem der impfstoff natürlich
einfach nur das ziel hat immunität
auszulösen
also da besteht schon eine sehr hohe
hoffnung in diesen impfstoffen aber bis
wir die haben noch mal ist es halt
wichtig sich an die abstandsregeln zu
halten kontakt zu minimieren und die
masken zu tragen
aus ihrer sicht hätte man die pandemie
an einem bestimmten punkt stoppen oder
wesentlich stärker abbremsen können das
jetzt eher eine frage die sich wieder
auf die vergangenheit bezieht
gab es momente wo sie sagen ach wenn wir
da vielleicht ein bisschen entschieden
gehandelt hätten wenn wir da etwas
restriktiver vorgegangen werde ich meine
das ist ja auch nach wie vor immer mal
thema dass man sagt okay jetzt bräuchte
jetzt vielleicht dann doch noch mal ein
richtig rigorosen shutdown
wie ist ihre einschätzung
ja auch das ist wieder ein sehr
schwieriges eine sehr schwierige antwort
das genau zu geben weil es gibt da
verschiedene aspekte erstens mal im
nachhinein ist man immer schlauer
das gilt in vielen fällen und so auch in
diesem und der andere punkt ist
natürlich ja der sicherste weg ist
niemand sieht mehr irgendjemanden dann
wird garantiert das virus erhebliche
schwierigkeiten haben sich zu verbreiten
das ist aus biologischer sicht
vielleicht der absolute schutz
aber es gibt natürlich viele andere
probleme antibes ja auch denken müssen
und die auch die politikerin und
politiker natürlich denken müssen
es gibt gesellschaftliche fragen
kinderbetreuung dann gibt es fragen
natürlich auch wer besucht denn da noch
andere wir sind als menschen auf kontakt
angewiesen wir sind darauf arbeit
angewiesen und auf ein miteinander und
das muss alles unter einen hut gebracht
werden und natürlich lernt man da und
manche entscheidungen sind besonders gut
im nachhinein andere hätte man
vielleicht auch anders treffen können
aber wie gesagt hinterher weiß man es
immer besser hier wird noch mal die
frage gestellt wann denn alle die
impfungen bekommen aber ich denke da
sind sie jetzt auch nicht der richtige
gesprächspartner für das würde ich jetzt
an der stelle noch einmal zurückstellen
das ist jetzt einfach organisatorische
fragen im prozess aber wenn wir jetzt
gerade doch noch mal gucken auch auf das
ist ja das eigentliche thema ein jahr
corona in deutschland wenn sie so
spontan jetzt das ganze nochmal bewerten
wobei sie sich natürlich auch die ganze
zeit schon mit diesem thema beschäftigen
aber was wäre jetzt aus ihrer sicht
vielleicht wenn das virus noch mal thema
und wir sind jetzt sondern mal in dieser
erfahrung wir haben uns schon mal erlebt
was würde man anders machen heute bei
der vielleicht nächsten variante oder
wenn
ja das nächste virus irgendwann
auftaucht was glauben sie wie würde sich
deutschland dann anders aufstellen
anders verhalten
ja wir haben sehr viel gelernt auf in
allen bereichen der gesellschaft haben
wir gelernt wir haben gelernt auch mehr
rücksicht aufeinander zu nehmen und
natürlich auch manche fragen kontrovers
miteinander zu diskutieren
aber es ist tatsächlich so dass dinge
die einfach sagen wir mal nicht die
höchste priorität in den jahren zuvor
hatten und fragen die natürlich schon
oft diskutiert wurden aber einfach nicht
nachhaltig genug beantwortet werden
konnten wie zum beispiel wie es unsere
versorgung mit schutzmaske wir sind
unsere medikamenten wie es unser
medikamentenversorgung die sind unsere
lieferketten abhängigkeiten alles diese
fragen sind natürlich jetzt diskutiert
worden und jetzt allen in deutschland
und auf der ganzen welt viel bewusster
geworden
das sind wichtige lerneffekte die es da
sicherlich gegeben hat im bereich der
virologie muss man sagen haben wir
natürlich im detail an diesem virus sehr
viel gelernt aber die methoden die
insbesondere und deutschland in den
vielen universitäten und
forschungseinrichtungen und labor
arztpraxen bereit standen die haben sich
am ende dann doch bewährt weil wir doch
ganz gut in der lage waren uns sehr
schnell an diese neue herausforderung
anzupassen könnte herr drosten recht
haben fragt denen sie hart wenn er sagt
der sommer 21 also der kommende sommer
wird immer noch hohe risiken warum sie
sich jetzt auf den sommer bezieht weiß
ich nicht aber ich gebe die frage jetzt
einfach mal so weiter ja der sommer wird
solange die impfungen noch nicht breit
ausgebracht werden können in der tat
hohe risiken auch wieder mit sich
bringen ein vorteil ist natürlich dass
wenn es warm wird die erkältungszeit
natürlich erfahrungsgemäß ja immer
abnimmt und viele menschen haben ja auch
gemerkt dass wir auch diesen zeiten
durch diese abstandsregel und die masken
weniger an den anderen
erkältungskrankheiten neben dem saas
kroner virus leiden aber im sommer wird
natürlich man wieder mehr abstand
voneinander halten wenn man kann wieder
nach draußen gehen
das hat vorteile andererseits ist es
natürlich auch so dass man trotzdem
bestimmte abstandsregeln weiterhin
einhalten muss erst recht wenn es
beispielsweise neue mutationen gibt die
sich dann möglicherweise doch noch
leichter verbreiten weil sie noch
weniger
virus brauchen um einen kranken zu
machen oder noch früher infektiös für
andere sein werden und deswegen müssen
wir da noch länger durchhalten
das ist so dass das zum einen
entspannung bringen kann aber zum
anderen eben auch weiterhin
durchhaltevermögen brauchen das meint
glaube ich christian thorsten unter
anderem auch mit dieser aussage
durchhaltevermögen ist gefragt frieda
mail fragt auf youtube noch mal zum pcr
test und zur impfung er würde gerne
wissen ob so genannte ausbrüche in
heimen ohne gravierenden gravierende
erkrankungen schreibt er auf die pcr
tests zurückzuführen sind dieser so
schreibt er spricht ja auch fragmente an
wie sie auch in folge der impfung durch
zellen produziert werden also wenn ich
das jetzt richtig verstehe sorgen die
tests dafür dass probleme entstehen
nein es ist so dass die impfung nicht zu
falsch positiven pcr testungen führt das
ist tatsächlich so man gibt einen
kleinen teil des erbguts dabei in den
muskel
das ist aber das erbgut für das bike
protein das ist das was aus drum diese
zackige hülle von dem saas corona virus
macht das wird dann im muskel von den
zellen selber hergestellt und ist dann
der trainer die trainingsfläche für die
wohn zellen und die immunabwehr es
entstehen dann eben auch antikörper das
was wir mit der pca untersuchen sind
ganz andere stellen des virus die im
inneren liegen die nichts mit dem
impfstoff zu tun haben es gibt zwar pcr
tests in deutschland nicht so verbreitet
sind die auch ein stück erbmaterial des
proteins ebendieses äußeren kranzes
suchen
da gibt es auch mal einen test der dann
in die irre geleitet wird nur man testet
niemals gegen ein ziel im erbgut man
testet mindestens gegen zwei oft sogar
gegen 3 so wurde übrigens auch die
britische variante entdeckt dafür
nämlich einer von drei genetischen
zielen aus die anderen beiden aber immer
funktioniert und auch hier in
deutschland haben wir hier keine sorge
dass wir das plötzlich nicht mehr
diagnostizieren können
wer geimpft ist der kann natürlich wenn
es schlecht läuft und tag später zwei
tage später an der infektion erkranken
das hat aber nichts mit der impfung zu
tun sondern das wäre auch ohne den von
leider passiert ich würde gerne zum
schluss noch mal den blick etwas weiten
und nicht nur deutschland in den
blick nehmen sozusagen in den focus wir
haben es in deutschland mit rund zwei
millionen infizierten zu tun ich habe
die zahlen für noch mal angeschaut
weltweit sind wir allerdings schon bei
über 100 millionen und sie auch als
bundeswehr angehöriger waren auch im
ausland stationiert also sie haben auch
den blick so zu sagen dafür was auch im
ausland passiert beziehungsweise wie die
verhältnisse dort auch sind also muss
man da nicht sagen darf er nun mal eine
pandemie ist das auch das ganz
wesentlich darüber mit entscheiden wird
wie es bei uns läuft wie sicher wir hier
in deutschland leben können sprich also
die frage wann auch die impfstoffe und
alles weitere im ausland auch in allen
ländern entsprechend verfügbar sein wird
ja da haben sie völlig recht das virus
ist weltweit verbreitet und ich habe
schon mal vorhin gesagt dieses virus
kennt auch keine grenzen
dementsprechend ist das
selbstverständlich für alle menschen auf
der welt eine große herausforderung
bedrohung und natürlich sind auch andere
länder die weniger gut aufgestellt sind
mit ihren ressourcen deswegen auch auf
die unterstützung angewiesen
unser institut hat im auftrag der
bundesregierung im rahmen der
ertüchtigung initiative der
bundesregierung auch bereits in ländern
wie beispielsweise in tunesien und den
g5 ländern g5 sahel ländern das ist mali
mauretanien tschad burkina faso nie leer
diagnostik unterstützung geleistet wir
hatten teams dort vor ort die dort
geholfen haben und dort hat man jetzt
eben auch mit dieser hilfe die
diagnostik verbessern können die
impfstoffe sind jetzt natürlich eine
weitere herausforderung und da ist es
natürlich auch so dass es weltweit
bestrebungen gibt auch hier diese länder
bei der impfung zu unterstützen
gut das nehme ich gerne nochmal somit
also können wir festhalten sie haben
sich verdient gemacht zum einen in
deutschland dafür dass wir jetzt eben
wissen womit man genau es zu tun haben
unter dem elektronenmikroskop aber die
bundeswehr sorgt auch wenn es sie da
gerade richtig verstanden habe dafür
dass auch in den ärmeren ländern dafür
was getan wird dass ich eben die
pandemien nicht ungehindert ausbreiten
kann
ich danke ihnen ganz herzlich für das
gespräch herr doktor würfel das war
jetzt einiges was wir denke ich
bearbeiten konnten wie gesagt wir haben
bisschen zurück geblickt wir haben auch
nach vorne blickt vielen dank für ihre
einschätzung und
ihre expertise dazu und alles gute für
ihre weitere arbeit vielen dank danke
gern geschehen
und auch an euch natürlich an dieser
stelle wie immer der dank dass ihr
mitgemacht habt
wir haben einige fragen denke ich daran
nehmen können
wir wollen euch noch den hinweis geben
dass wir morgen auch wieder einen
livestream machen den allerdings schon
vormittags und zwar ab 10 uhr
da geht es dann um das urteil im prozess
auch ein spannendes thema euch einen
schönen abend und bis hoffentlich morgen
wenn ihr mögt